PROFESSOR: This is the answer.
Tan of 2 k a plus delta.
It's a little messy, no wonder.
Just plotted this functions.
[INAUDIBLE] Sin k plus a
cosh kappa a [INAUDIBLE]
plus a prime over kappa
cosh a prime a sinh kappa a.
You have sin a prime a sinh.
The sinh causes outer
[INAUDIBLE] the same
but this one changes.
Centered here, k prime
over kappa cos k prime
a cosh kappa a.
So it's a well-defined
expression,
if you know the
number of kappa a,
you can calculate everything.
Let me just make sure
you can see that.
If you know-- if you
said, for example, ka,
this is a natural variable.
ka is just-- the k is related
to the energy direction.
So ka has no limits, call it u.
Then you have two parameters
of the square well [INAUDIBLE],,
a depth we don't and
a height we want.
So there's natural to
define just [INAUDIBLE]
would have z 0 squared
which is 2m v 0
a squared over h squared.
You also define z 1 squared
[INAUDIBLE] as 2m v1
a squared over h squared.
And then the energy--
we can do another
thing, we're going
to find the energy divided
say, by v 1 to be little e.
And that's reasonable
because these energies
is compared always with
v 1, and we're solving--
we've solved this
problem in the domain
when the energy
is less than v 1,
and that's why we'll
have kappas here,
and if energy was
bigger than v 1,
you would have trigonometric
functions everywhere.
Now you can switch from
trigonometric to hyperbolic
by analytic continuation,
letting and angle
become imaginary, a
trigonometric function becomes
a hyperbolic function.
Most of us are
rather comfortable
doing this at the beginning,
because of the matter of sine
if you mess up a sine,
it's a big problem.
But at the end of the day, it
actually saves a lot of work.
So a little of that in
the homework you will see.
But at any rate, this is
valued for e in this range.
And therefore this ratio
is h squared k squared.
You can put an a squared
over 2m v 1 a squared.
And you can see
a u squared here.
And-- I'm sorry, not there.
A u squared here, and
the h squared divided
here gives you a z 1.
So this is u squared
over z 1 squared.
A couple of extra things--
I'm just putting it
here because if you ever
have the curiosity of doing
this plots, this may help.
k prime squared is
related to the energy,
therefore u squared
and v 0 z 1 squared.
This is-- c 0 squared,
[INAUDIBLE] 0.
And for the other
one, kappa a squared
is equal to z 1 squared
minus u squared.
So everything becomes a
function of u Wherever
you have a kappa prime a
you have a square root of u.
Now, somebody has to give you
the values of z 0 and z 1.
Those are the data of
the potential-- z 0
and z 1 are numbers
you know then.
Therefore you know kappa a
is a function of u, kappa--
k prime a is a function
of u, and ka, which is u.
Therefore this equation becomes
a function of u [INAUDIBLE]
this arc tangent here,
and so for delta.
It's messy.
There's no-- remember I
mentioned the other day
the fact that you could do
trigonometric identities,
and so for tan delta here.
But then this I don't think
simplifies when you solve that.
It becomes just a bigger mess.
You did solve for tan
delta, it's very messy.
So anyway, let's leave it there.
Are there any questions
in solving this problem?
So in principle, we solved it.
I didn't plot
anything, so you still
don't have any insight
as to what's happening.
But you've learned in
principle how to solve it.
Any questions?
OK, so let's plot this then.
Maybe I should start here.
OK.
I'll start here.
Oh, if I'm going to plot,
I have to choose things.
So we'll choose z 0
squared equals to 1,
or z 0 equals to 1.
And z 1 squared equals to 5.
So we put a big barrier there.
And now let's go delta
as a function of ka or u.
Now, from this equation, we
see that u and the little e
must be at most 1 for our
formulas to be correct.
So u must be up to square--
up to z 1, because you must
keep this ratio less than 1.
So we can plot u up
to square root of 5.
5, here's 2.
And that's it.
And here we're going
to plot delta of u.
And here is minus
pi over 2 minus pi.
And so what does
it do, the phase?
There no way you can guess,
I think, from this formula.
I could not guess
from this formula.
So we could try to imagine--
it's possible to guess,
actually, after you've
solved this week's homework.
You probably will
have a good guess
that the phase shift begins
with minus 2ka, as if
with very little energy
you reflect back here.
So there will be a shift that
is calculable without doing
any work.
So it begins linearly.
And it represents
a time advance.
So it goes linearly
and negative.
That's how it begins.
Because for very little energy,
it's going to bounce back.
And you know that the
delay is proportional
to this derivative.
So must be negative like that.
So then what does it do?
It crosses this point,
which is almost pi,
and here is what something
quite remarkable happens.
That some value you star,
which is about 1.8523, I think.
That's what I calculated.
Let's see [INAUDIBLE].
The face that is almost minus pi
suddenly jumps very, very fast,
crosses pi over 2, and then
about [INAUDIBLE] something
like this.
I don't know what else
it does, because we
haven't calculated it.
But it jumps very fast.
Almost a value of pi.
Now, let me-- this
is quite interesting.
If you think of what we
used to call the scattering
amplitude as squared
was sin squared delta.
The amplitude of the
scattered wave, sin
squared delta, the amplitude
of the scattered wave
is going to be quite
large here, it's
going to be 1, which is the
maximum, as squared is here.
So I want to keep these
two blackboards aligned.
So here it goes like this.
It's going to go up like this,
and do this, and broadly go
down, and then
very sharply go up.
More sharply, at least.
Go up and then
something like that.
So here it is.
This point over here has a
strong scattering amplitude,
but there's nothing too
dramatic happening here.
This sine corresponds to
time advanced, the derivative
is negative.
And time advanced cannot
be too large, as you know.
On the other hand,
here is time delayed,
and apparently they
can't be very large.
So we think this must
be the resonance,
and this is not a resonance,
even though the scattering
amplitude is bigger.
So we continue here,
and plot the time--
interestingly, the
amplitude inside the well.
So here it is.
How does the wave function
become, through this constant,
inside the well?
And indeed, the this confirms
that nothing very special
is happening here.
What happens now is some
sort of behavior like this,
and a big jump here, in which
the amplitude apparently--
I have not quite
confirmed this number,
it's at least a value 3.
[INAUDIBLE] very
large and short.
I should have room for one more
plot [INAUDIBLE] the star plot
of this thing is--
I'll do it compressed here.
The total delay, 1
over a d delta dk.
Well, it begins
negative, and remember
that when we did the
1 over a, d delta dk,
this is a pure number.
It expresses the delay
in terms of the time
that it would take to
travel the inside region.
So how many-- if you would
get a 1, or a minus 1,
it's just a delay of
the size of the time
needed to travel back and forth.
So actually this goes
a little negative
at the beginning-- we
know the derivative is
like that-- and
when you plot this,
you see that it's
very sharp, and it's
a value of about fourteen.
Fourteen times gets delayed from
what you would expect naturally
of the time that it should have
spent travelling back and forth
A gigantic time delay.
A peak in the time delay.
Peak in time delay.
Peak in the amplitude
inside the well.